greetings of peace from the Dene show I
have a very interesting story I wanted
to share with you to me I considered a
miracle right under my nose and many
people can relate to this you get a
broken toe a broken arm a broken neck a
broken back and some people get a broken
heart we're gonna be talking about this
at the end not you got this x-ray this
x-ray the third toe down you can see the
fracture you see it okay good guess
whose toe that is I'll tell you in a
minute I was training gracie brazilians
uture that's what i chamber black belt
professor in this art amazing art and I
was passing what's called the guard one
side the other side as I jumped over my
toll got caught on the mat snap that's
the toe it looked like that an inch and
a half two inches Lear to the left I was
really excited in the match and I wanted
to finish and my logic when I took a
double take I looked and I said you know
what I better stop I better relax after
I got myself together I made two units
of prayer rock at 2 rakaats and thank
the crater for the 360 joints of my body
and now I knew I was gonna need help to
get through this another challenge in
life and many people go through far
worse but one of the amazing benefits
right there war was thinking and
reflecting those people that have lost
limbs legs you know if the real is just
a toe and I was really set back because
I was the one that got his toe broke
during his training but that was one of
the benefits right there because we know
that the believer as the prophet saw
Sodom had said he said that no affair
nothing affects the believer but except
that is good for him your state of mind
needs to be right so I got my state of
mind together because as the hadith says
when good reaches you you're thankful to
the Creator and when an affliction
reaches you you're patient that's good
for you too so we had to be patient so I
made the prayer at that time for the
creditor give me strength and then I
started to reflect it can always be
worse you always got to look to those
who have less and those who have gone
through worse like many people who are
being oppressed all over the world and
they're just getting blown to pieces and
they got body parts that they're losing
so this was at Oh God when I was going
to get through it and I was going to get
through it and come back much
stronger inshallah God wanted so at this
moment now I relaxed after the prayer
when he got the x-ray and what I thought
it happened happened the x-ray said that
it was fractured what do we do now
really all you can do is tape the
adjacent toe to the broken toe and let
it rest let it heal and you can't
believe just from this small little toe
how many of the things that we take for
granted walking for instance because of
a broken toe now you're on crutches
because of a broken toe maybe you can't
do the jumping jacks you're immobilized
somewhat amazing and I was really
fascinated with the eternal self defense
the repair kit mechanism that's in the
body let me give you an example if you
were to take a pencil for instance and
you'd snapped it broke it right or if
you took a piece of paper you ripped it
no matter what you try to do to try to
put it together maybe you can tape it
right you can do some things like that
but I'm talking about if you just put
this together and you left in any
environment
for it to come back to its original
state it's not going to happen
no way but the body who's healing it
when you get a black eye when you get a
bump when you get a bruise or in my case
you get a broken bone now of course now
sometimes you need some human
intervention we're not talking about
that but even that human intervention
that the human gives the body is still
the blessing from the Creator with this
internal mechanism self repair kid
inside your body who installed that
that's the one who created you so now it
was getting to work the blood was
rushing to this area as you can see to
the break and it was a border created
around the cartilage was coming back the
bone started to heal and Hum did it live
this was amazing and that's what I
really started to reflect about and it
really made me more grateful and
thankful I wanted to share that with you
but there is something else that also
you know that's the physical break in
the physical body but now there's also
something more important than this
because that's something you don't even
have to ask for right that's
merciful and loving the crater is but
now many people let's take for example
Robin Williams many people he just
committed suicide not too long ago and
many have followed in his footsteps
killing themselves because they fall
into despair because they give up on
life because they got or have had a
spiritual breakdown because of a broken
heart
many people they give up and we want to
give the solution to that also another
great benefit but this is something you
have to ask for it this is something you
have to see you have to recognize the
one who put this self to fit repair kit
in your body the one who gave you the
air that you breathe the one who gave
you life will give you death the one who
loves you your Creator the one who is
healing you every day from your physical
ailments that's the one who will heal
you from your spiritual ailments which
are even more far more important because
when you got a dead heart then you're
gonna have a dead body you're just like
a walking dead person you follow them
you're alive but really dead you know
what I'm talking about and then you turn
to substance abuse alcohol drugs sex
abuse domestic violence of all of this
because you've got a broken heart so how
do we fix that broken heart one is to
acknowledge the one who is full of mercy
and love the one who's repairing your
body physically and the one who gave you
the body the one who gave you life will
give you death the one who created you
you acknowledge him and then you become
thankful to him ask him to fix that
heart that broke it heart ask him and
believe me he will definitely pull you
out of despair pull you out of
depression and he will fix your heart
that's a guarantee so ask for the
guidance him alone no intermediaries
between you and the one who created you
your maker the one who made you that's
right so I hope you got the benefit from
this this was my story I wanted to share
it with you make sure that you subscribe
to the Dean show like us on the Facebook
on the Twitter and we have a full fledge
for those that turn in it for the first
time we have a show that we do weekly
talking about really important issues
purpose of life the meaning of life at
the D show
komm thank you see you next time peace
be with you